and this is the frontier that i think
most people have not gotten to yet
is this is all made possible because
of really corruption of government for
years i used to tell people write the
ftc
i've met with people in the ftc i used
to exchange letters with them i don't
even bother
anymore these are we're having a
discussion that i swear i could not have
had 10 years ago
it just wouldn't nobody would ask these
questions it was just considered out of
bounds
[Music]
robert you're the expert in this
industry and
in this video i want to get beyond the
basics a lot of videos on multi-level
marketing they cover sort of they do
like a recap of the generic industry
but now i want to go deeper because as
i've looked into multi-level marketing i
feel like the conversation needs to
progress
beyond the sort of uh important
but also sort of over discussed facts
that you know
people are losing their life savings we
know this we know that there you know
a lot of these big companies have major
major problems but i want to move beyond
that
and talk about how do we get further
into
regulation reform and i know that
touches on some very serious issues of
like
government corruption regulatory capture
et cetera
now i think it's impossible to get into
this without mentioning that you have a
book coming out and it's called
ponzinomics for those of you who don't
know uh first maybe i should say thank
you for coming on the show
and then let's get into this very
welcome ponzinomics yeah first of all
a made-up term combining the term ponzi
which is a form of fraud robbing peter
to pay paul
with economics the idea here is to
combine the two
because in what we've got today
is a a belief system the belief system
is a
pseudo economics portrayed in the in
terms of sales
marketing business language multi-level
marketing
which we'll get into itself is a pseudo
economic term you did in the book you
talked about the history
of multi-level marketing which not a lot
of people know i certainly didn't i sort
of thought oh
amway i've sort of heard of this thing
called nutrilite
but i was really sort of surprised that
carl rinberg who's
most people think of the founder of mlm
who he created neutralite which was the
precursor to amway
he was actually a massive failure in his
business career
like it was shocking like this is not a
guy we've lionized this person or
amway's lionized him
they put a statue up they they wrote a
biography for him
but this guy was kind of as as you point
out an abject failure
can you speak a little to that so i
began the book speaking about carl
renberg
for that very purpose i wanted to
show the origins where did all this come
from
and as you see the the the origins are
quite
banal and mythologized
in in reality they are quite banal um
just um a small uh
sort of fortune seeker guy
not uncommon in that era particularly
um and and and
ended up with a small vitamin company
and in the in the era when vitamin pills
were just
exploding into the market as a sort of
new technology
and uh he ends up uh
largely failing throughout a tiny little
company
based in southern california never
really moved out of that area
and in the end uh is approached by two
individuals
who were also failures in their own in
their own careers i
you know i don't say that
disrespectfully but
they they had not really achieved much
in life
and uh but between the two of them
they uh sitting in in a
sort of temporary work in a munitions
factory during the war
and concocting a plan
and the plan was a
a variation it it included elements of
selling direct selling door-to-door
selling but it also incorporated
elements
of ponzi which had occurred only 20
years before
and the chain letter which had occurred
only 10 years before which was a mania
in this country in the mid 30s during
the depression
where you would put money in an envelope
send it to a certain number of people
and they would get it and send it to a
certain number or other people
a classic chain yeah at the end of the
chain the money flows up to you
and it was a a folly a mania but it
occurred in that era so
these things were all sort of combined
into this distortion of direct selling
in which the salesperson ultimately
became the customer
unwittingly and he redeemed himself
and i'm using he here because at that
time most of the
salespeople were men that's all changed
now
they they would redeem their uh position
by recruiting other people and getting
some of the money from the other people
so there were elements of of abuse of
sales people
in the direct selling business and the
one of these inventors was
a manager who has for years had
recruited sales people
never fully informing them of what they
were up against what their
costs and time and so on so that was
that was not
an uncommon practice uh and as they say
the incorporation of the ponzi and the
chain letter
into this to create what they called the
plan
so they purposely kept it vague and
unidentified
the plan and when they implemented this
plan
at the end of 1945 that little company
went from about two thousand dollars a
month
in total revenue which is cover all
their cost
into becoming rapidly a multi-million
dollar business
i mean in the course of several years
just like
a couple years yes yeah and that
and nothing about the company itself
changed so clearly
it's the bit something's going on
obviously with the business model and of
course the business model was
multi-level marketing it was the
invention of multi-level marketing and
it sold the endless chain the unlimited
opportunity you recruit just two
and they recruit four and eight and
sixteen and pretty soon you have an
army of people underneath you and um
and each one is making exactly the same
promise to the ones below
no matter how far it extends it pretends
that saturation doesn't exist it
pretends that markets
have no limits on them that sales people
cannot
have over competition and so on all the
fundamentals
that exist it denies so it was engaged
in a
a large process of re-education
diversion of getting people to think
about the possibilities
rather than the simple realities of it
so from the
from the beginning it was always a sale
of a
of a a kind of snake oil but not the
vitamins
i mean the vitamins really were more or
less the bait and the trap
and whether the vitamins worked or not
it didn't matter they weren't fda
approved
they didn't have to be and so that was
really just the the mechanism
for it since then we've seen a myriad of
products the products
really truly don't matter they are not
what multi-level
marketing is about the products are
almost a pretense for the whole
pyramid scheme i mean it seems to me it
seems like almost an
in-game currency like i don't know if
you know in video games there's all
these micro transactions that happen
where you put in money
and then they give you like this in-game
currency which is pretty much
meaningless because it's just kind of
like traded within the game itself
and then someone laid the company really
cashes out
at the top and they're the ones who make
all the money that's the way
i think of multi-level marketing now
sort of a disguised pyramid scheme
to just sort of get around the
technicality so whether it's vitamins or
essential oils
it doesn't fundamentally matter that's
your perspective as well that's your
core argument isn't it precisely the
product the products are merely just
lures they are the the cheese on the
mouse trap
and if you were to tell the the poor
mouse
uh only about the cheese
and and and talk to him about the
quality of the cheese is it old cheese
is it good cheese
uh what country did the cheese come from
and so on
uh how does it taste without telling
them that the cheese is set on a
carefully designed lethal machine a
little device that will snap
its neck you wouldn't have helped the
mouse at all and that's what happens a
lot is a lot of journalists
talk about the cheese and uh they get
very involved in this the essential oil
really cure cancer and can can they
actually stop aging with this cream
and so on and this is the exact
discussion
that multi-level marketing promoters
want to
occur your whole business
is fraudulent yeah instead of the whole
business is not a business at all
it doesn't qualify as a business now i
would l
i actually want to talk to you about
this because i can tell so you've been
at this a long time
and part of your book is sort of
geared talking about i
i would characterize it as maybe your
frustration with talking to journalists
who always seem to grasp sort of a
half-truth or if they grasp the whole
truth they don't print the whole truth
and they instead print uh sort of like a
watered-down version which includes of
both sides ism of like well
robert fitzpatrick says it's all
fraudulent but the dsa says it's not
which is like a glorified
it's a lobbying group owned by mlm
but don't you think that's changed a
little bit with the advent
whether it's because of the internet or
people are waking up to this scheme
and enough people have talked about it
where now it's not that uncommon
for people just popu popularly or
in the media to be like mlm oh yeah
don't you mean a pyramid scheme
that's penetrating more isn't it
absolutely very much so and having again
we as we began here 22 years
i've been watching this i can
certainly recall when it was not like
this
it was worse if you said what we're
saying right now
um well you you were considered al
almost
um possibly a conspiracy theorist
someone who has only a a grudge or
he has certain some kind of malevolent
intention
uh you you simply have a negative view
of
of entrepreneurship maybe you're
anti-capitalist
your anti-business somehow you hate
people who succeed
and so on so the it was very difficult
to say
this uh and the media almost never
approached it they
uh absorbed what was in the popular
culture
at that time and that popular culture
uh got shaped uh starting about 1980.
this is another part of the history
that people don't realize prior to 1980
and let's say going back to the 1960s
when the first when these multi-level
marketing companies really began to
make an uh an imprint in the country and
hundreds of thousands of people started
joining them and there were more of them
that began to be more than just
neutralite or amway there were more of
them at that point
regulators began receiving complaints
huge numbers of complaints
and realized something was wrong here
and so at that point
laws were passed in many states
anti-pyramid scheme laws we had
no law prior to that in addition
in congress 1973 a bill was proposed by
quite a famous senator a senator walter
mondale
that was to make pyramid selling a
criminal offense that is a felony
in some of the states as inc it is in
california right now
the law the anti-endless chain law
is it treats it as a felony it's a
felony offense
so then that that law was passed in 1968
it was signed by ronald reagan who was
governor at that time
so what does that tell us well it tells
us that there was a clarity
among within government and among
regulators in the 60s and into the 70s
that inherently any plan any proposition
based on the endless chain
that is uh your your investment can be
uh you can gain a return on your
investment only by getting more
investors
they want to you recruit five and they
recruit five
and it always presupposes that
everyone's going to make their money
back
because there's always more people but
obviously that's right
so this is an inherent inherently
deceptive
it's not just deceptive it results in
harm because
the vast majority of people have to be
at the end of that chain
and they're going to lose so it can
cause
loss on a large scale they had also
known
that such schemes like this can create
mass manias
so large numbers of people can sort of
come under the spell of this
and it can cause large societal harm
which we have seen in other countries
such as albania
where an entire government was brought
down by allowing one of the
several of these schemes to run rampant
right so
what happened well what happened was
politics
uh and primarily as i try to describe in
my book
uh the in ponzi omix book the
player the major player here was the
amway corporation
and the two founders of amway who had
spent 10 years
in the first multi-level marketing
neutralite
they became extremely politically active
one was the
chairman of the u.s chamber of commerce
and the other was
uh a treasurer for the national
republican
party who was a chief fundraiser that's
so unbelievable that's richard devos
you're talking about yeah and jay van
andel yeah
now it's worth noting that you guys all
should know at home
who's our secretary of education right
now
might recognize that last name devos uh
it goes all the way to the tippity top
and that's what i mean by we have to go
deeper in the conversation because if
you only talk about
herbalife in isolation you miss
why the federal trade commission would
only find them with a slap on the wrist
instead of actually banning them all
together when it should be
illegal to be a pyramid scheme that's
what we say it is
but instead they're found to have done
pyramid scheme things
and then we slap them on the wrist and
say don't do it again when that's their
whole business model
that's what i mean is that's what i want
to see
go in the pop culture so give us a
rundown a brief history
you said it starts with amway where did
it go from there so they realize they're
about to get regulated out of existence
they have this huge case going up like
up against them how did they get out of
that
yes so certainly
some circumstances sort of conspired to
to do this too
because they had some power they had
significant power already in michigan
and they were
already a large company multi-million
dollar company and there were several of
them
but the law the laws had been passed in
various states against endless chain
the regulatory community recognized
these things for what they were
these were glorified chain letters they
understood these things to be very
harmful and inherently deceptive so they
the government acted to shut them down
to literally kill multi-level marketing
i won't say in its infancy but in let's
say in its teen years because it had now
begun to multiply into multiple
companies
many more people are involved and so
they prosecuted them
the original prosecution would have been
from the department of justice as a
criminal offense
but that law didn't pass it passed in
the senate but failed in the house
then it moved over to the federal trade
commission
now bear in mind the federal trade
commission already now is a huge
concession
because the ftc does not bring any
criminal charges it cannot
it only deals in civil offense so it
treats
it only as a
sort of a bad practice and they even
call it that an unfair and deceptive
business practice so again we had no law
against pyramid schemes
so the ftc interpreted a pyramid scheme
a vague term to be under the general
category unfair and deceptive trade
practice
and they prosecuted the three largest
ones at that time
which was costco holiday magic and amway
the first two
were run by marginal characters
holiday magic was run by a member of the
john birch society
he had run against ronald reagan in
california he was quite a radical
individual
and his company was shut down
the other one was glenn turner who was a
kind of clownish character
both are dead now turner died fairly
recently
he had a cleft palate which he used as a
kind of brand for himself like if a poor
boy from cal
from south carolina yeah can make it
and he wore these gaudy clothes he drove
in big fancy cadillacs and
he built a so-called castle in orlando
florida and
so and he was both of them also
sold mine training programs uh along
with it
those two were shut down but when it got
to amway
amway was quite different uh again the
two founders were
heavily embedded in the most powerful
political and financial organizations in
the country
they portrayed themselves as very pious
christians
actually they were from a fairly extreme
form of
dutch calvinism in a little sect up in
michigan
and and they tried to connect
their scheme to capitalism itself
to entrepreneurship to self-employment
and so it kind of rang well it it it
resonated
with republican politics which were
against labor unions and so on
so when the government's prosecuting
amway which they launched the case in
1974 7475
an unusual event occurred the president
of the united states richard nixon
resigns
in disgrace because of watergate as we
know
and his vice president takes over now
this is
exactly during the time the federal
trade commission is prosecuting amway
and seeking to shut it down as it had
just shut down its two largest
competitors
but the the new president is jerry ford
jerry ford is a congressman from
lansing michigan oh no amway happens to
be his
among his largest financial backers
and so they hold a private meeting this
is all documented in the news media at
the time
they hold a private meeting with him and
the white house while they're being
prosecuted
by the government they hold a private
meeting with the president of the united
states yes
and so uh by this time
uh by 1979 the other
member of the two devos at the
republican side has become
the main financial fundraiser for the
new
coming incoming president ronald reagan
so by 79 when the ftc renders its
decision
effectively they dropped the case
against
amway and the
so amway was legalized and in so doing
multi-level marketing became quote
legalized
and then from the next 12 years
which was eight years of the reagan
administration
four more years of his vice president
george h.w
bush there were no prosecutions and
during that time
they expanded into other countries and
they solidified the
narrative the mythological narrative
that
multi-level marketing is actually direct
selling
actually a pyramid scheme it's it's not
synonymous
now let so this is one of the things you
talk about
in your book where you say basically
amway and this decision created
sort of this idea of almost a unicorn
mlm
which is an mlm that's based on
actually not on recruitment but actually
has this element of retail sales that
makes it different
and you know sort of legal and i think
that's what people
are imagining when they say oh no this
is like a legit
mlm as opposed to a pyramid scheme
they say yeah this is actually based on
sales
rather than rather than recruitment but
your point is is
show me the unicorn where does it exist
has anyone
seen one what does this look like like
the whole presumption of the federal
trade commission their whole
definition is sort of that oh well there
are these bad
mlms that are pyramid schemes but then
there's good mlms
that are actually selling something to
the broader public
yeah but as anyone who's ever uh
encountered an mlm knows
all their products you've never heard of
before you will not find them
on the shelves of walmart or h-e-b
does anybody care in the federal trade
commission
does anybody know that this is happening
have you seen anybody actually push back
against this
because it seems so obvious when you do
the most modest amount of research
yeah well um before i do that i want to
emphasize the idea that
a a scheme that had been treated as a
felony offense only a few years before
suddenly became the exemplary
model of capitalism in america
that by 1982 ronald reagan
spoke at an amway conference as the
president
of the united states and called it
capitalism
in america so really this is an
extraordinary powerful
government endorsement that
imposed itself on public thinking and
when you have that kind of authority
backing something you can actually
literally doubt your own
thinking not believe your own eyes
because
maybe i'm wrong i mean they called it
direct selling
they said it's it's the greatest example
of american entrepreneurship
and they claim that people make money at
this
even though i didn't so
this is where the imprint came on
multi-level marketing in the popular
mind even if you've never been to an mlm
meeting
this is where you know you you got this
idea
because and and there was no really
anyone else to speak of
in the mid 80s a couple of books were
written
uh by people who had been in it uh one
was called fake it till you make it by
phil
clark kearns and the other was called um
amway the the cult of free enterprise
and it was written by stephen
butterfield and they're remarkable books
for
describing what goes on inside
these programs and how they work and so
on
but they were lone voices um
so there was no lobby to tell the to
push the truth
but there's an enormous lobby to push
the lie
and if you're a politician and this is
where i think
it is so hard for people to grasp this
because it's so crass in a way it's it's
it's hard to understand this
to accept it let's say we can understand
but accept it
politics is power there's no power among
the
all the hundreds of thousands of victims
of multi-level marketing
right they're not organized they have no
spokesman that's right they have no
political voice whereas
the mlm industry has a lobby on k street
a professional association they hire the
best lawyers
they have professional they've used
nolan
uh what's it hillary knowlton the
company that promoted the cigarette
industry
so i mean they have this expertise in
distraction
and and so politics came in
you know to play to the people inside
the ftc to your question do they know
i know they do know i know they know
because i've talked to them
wow but they keep their head down
there's no career advancement for
speaking up against this
that at the ftc agency level which
remember is a small agency
it really is is a tiny little agency
they are funded they operate under the
presidency
funded by congress so
they're bounded uh they're captured in
effect they are captured
and for years i used to tell people
write the ftc
i've met with people in the ftc i used
to exchange letters with them
i don't even bother anymore and they
aren't even the appropriate agency
anyway
if this uh criminal matter you're saying
it should be
considered as fraud pure and simple
and just let the law follow it from
there a fraud being
a calculated deception that involving
money that results in harm and
is understood to cause harm by the
people perpetrating and that's really
all we're looking at here
it's a kind of racket and that's
that's really what um if people could
get there
but you know the first thing is to break
the prevailing narrative that it's
business
yes yes i mean and and what you have to
do
if you're gonna understand that maybe
the best way to do it
is to strip away the fanfare sort of all
the well what about this company what
about that one
and you identify first it seems to me
well what is a pyramid scheme
what's it what makes a pyramid scheme a
pyramid scheme
and um you know correct me if i'm wrong
but i basically you have this endless
chain
which we've talked about you've got a
pay-to-play system so you have to buy
in you have to buy in to be a part of it
to make money
and then you have a recruiting mandate
where you're like okay i have to go get
somebody to come bring them back into my
scheme
and then you have this money transfer up
right those are like the four
elements of the pyramids it's the four
elements yes what is different for those
of you at home
in an mlm it's every single one of those
components
and really nothing else they try to harp
on this were
were retail selling but if you've been
in an mlm and i
it's almost something that um you know
you can't encourage people to
go commit harm to themselves and their
you know their family but
it's an amazing experience at least i've
been to some of the meetings
because it's immediately apparent that
nobody's interested in selling the
product
so you you don't even have to like think
about this if you just go to one of
their little
hilton seminars it's immediately
apparent that nobody cares about
no one's excited about their you know uh
their cleaning solution
everyone's excited about going out and
recruiting and so
when you strip away you know the well
amway's been around
for 27 years if you strip away the
charismatic speakers the prosperity
gospel that
underlies all of this
at the fundamental level it's a pyramid
scheme with a few little bells and
whistles on it to try to hide it
um so i don't so i think that's
what has to be done is you have to strip
away the smoke
and the mirrors and realize that this is
something that's been sort of
it's really they've gotten away with
sort of murder through the use of
politics and power and money
i mean that's the whole it's the whole
thing
politics power money and propaganda
and uh that's another element to this
is um very sophisticated propaganda
which includes
discrediting people like myself making
sure there are no professors at
universities who would make a
an in-depth study of this i've talked
with people at universities and they
would tell me
well we can't get into that subject
because well we have no funding
and if we were to develop a proposal for
studying it
most likely the only people who would
fund it would be the mlm companies which
would
destroy our demand that they yeah so
so they just stale stay away from uh
you know they stay out of the whole
subject so
yes i i think it really requires people
to
sort of set aside that prevailing
narrative
to shift their language away from
business and thinking of it as sales and
business and just start from the premise
well
what is it what actually is it and and
you already did that you if you just
break that model down
and what are the four elements of it and
those are the four elements
and as you said if you set
foot in one of these meetings you
discover immediately
it isn't about selling products also
the very idea that you would have a skin
care or lipstick or leggings
clothing kitchenware
that you could personally make a living
from your home
in the 21st century by yourself
selling such commodity goods that are
available
in stores everywhere online everywhere
you know instantly it can be delivered
to your house
no middle man why on god's earth would
you need
10 layers of managers and in between
middlemen and sales people
why would you need a personal
salesperson it's impossible
you might as well think you could make a
living selling apples on the street
you know and and it's just a ridiculous
even more so
become wildly successful they unlimited
wealth by selling your apples on the
street like that's the
that's the real argument um you know one
thing that i've been
fascinated by and it touches it it's an
overlap between
sort of what you and i sort of do my
kind of audience knows me more for these
charlatans promising home-based
businesses
is this idea of think which you get into
in your book
which is uh early on the nutralite
founders had an issue
where they were promising these
miraculous cures
with their like whatever vitamin they
said it can cure cancer whatever
alzheimer's whatever it is
and then the the uh was it fda
fda comes up and they say hey you can't
do that knock knock knock we're gonna
shut you down
and they go okay we'll stop doing that
and they reworded the language to say it
without saying it
and this is what i find all the time
where
i'll see a sales letter that'll say
you know this kind of mysterious drug
that doctors don't want you to know
about
will cure you of alzheimer's whatever
this isn't even mlm
and then at the bottom it'll say well
the fda hasn't been
you know they'll they'll say they're not
making any claims while making all the
claims
how does how has this come about in
multi-level marketing
what has have they done to sort of
say it without saying it in terms of
their income claims and all of these
things
yeah uh they have become sort of masters
of
language let's start with the term
multi-level marketing itself
which was coined in the 1980s
so that era that i spoke about when the
federal government and the state
governments were passing
laws banning pyramid selling
and endless change that's what they
called them pyramid selling
and endless chains they had experience
with ponzi
they knew about chain letters they knew
about referral selling you know where
uh i sell it to you but don't worry you
can get it free
because after you give me two names and
they buy
you know i'll give you your money back
well how am i gonna get two other people
they can do the same
right so nobody ever pays for it it's
always free
so this is the culture that multi-level
marketing had come from
and uh so the government understood that
this looks like flimflam fraud this is a
scam
straight out and they couldn't even
imagine
actually the early regulators that this
thing would ever endure because
they didn't understand that these people
could silence victims with shame
they never imagined these things would
amass enough political power
that they could cut off the regulators
but then in the after they got this one
ruling
in 1979 and then they had an
administration who
basically shut down the ftc for the next
12 years
on that subject pyramids
they coined a new term multi-level
marketing
as they say sounds like a business term
sounds kind of like franchising
direct to customer b2b something you
know sounds professional
you're right multi-level marketing is
very innocuous
sounding it sounds professional it's
very
it's it is sort of orwellian
in that it is absolutely orwellian it
was created exactly as an orwellian term
to divert you from the reality that
you're seeing and experiencing
but you're calling it multi-level
marketing and as you say that word
you're telling yourself it's a business
what you experienced was a scam
but you called the scam a business so
you can't
actually uh interpret that
correctly in your brain the word level
kind of sounds like oh yeah like a
national sales manager
regional promotion yeah you move up with
nobody gets promoted
in multi-level marketing there are no
you know competency communications
no those levels are merely markers
of your recruiting that's all they are
and there
are reward levels assigned to each of
those levels
but they have nothing to do you're not a
manager you don't manage
you're not responsible there's no
product flowing from one level to the
next level
it all comes from the company these are
just markers
and fundamentally it's almost a marker
of how many body bags you're
accumulating underneath you exactly
because
the vast majority something like i mean
it depends on
exactly how you're running the math but
somewhere in the realm of 97 to 99
percent of these people
every year every year
over a multiple year remember that two
or three or one percent whatever it
might be for the company
that's in a one year time frame so that
one or two percent they stay the same
they they're there the next year
the 97 are churning at a 50 to 80
percent
so it's a whole new crowd so if you add
up all the people who had been in
let's say five years and say how many of
them
made a profit now you're way way less
than the 0.01
yeah yes the final word i want to put in
about multi-level marketing is the most
important one marketing
mlms do not market we just said you
can't know the brands
they don't advertise market means
i have something a good or a service and
i deliver it or provide the service
to someone else there is a market for my
product for my business
the people in multi-level marketing are
the market
there is no external market being served
by
multi-level marketing quote sales people
they buy they have to buy or they lose
their position
the majority of the business of the
company is
generated by the purchases of the people
inside the chain
who are classified legally as
contractors
buying it so-called wholesale price so
they are their own internal market they
make their own market
there is no market out there being
served
so when you say multi-level marketing
you've kind of implied there's a
business structure kind of like a
corporation
you've implied there are levels that
kind of show levels of responsibility
and you've sort of implied that this is
a system of delivering goods and
services
to some external market no that's true
yeah if people can just imagine because
it's it's
you kind of have to get to the point
where you can look at
mlms for the weird strange thing that
they are
um and stop seeing them as as a business
altogether
if you imagine that google for example
giant corporation
the only reason way it made its money no
one used it on pl
on the planet earth except the people
who worked for google except the
software engineers they're the only ones
who paid the salaries they
it's like it's like this strange thing
wait sorry they paying themselves
and you come to find out that they're
not the people at the bottom
aren't making any money at all in fact
they're losing money and they're just
end up paying the people at the top
you're like well this is insane which
gets us sort of to the uh
the what you call the big lie of immalam
can you explain what the big lie of mlm
is
so the the big lie is that it is a
business
that it is uh the two biggest lies are
that it is direct selling which is what
we've been speaking about
which is like when you sell at something
door to door and people used to do this
yeah and there is a little bit of it
still left in the world
insurance salesmen still come to your
house and sell the product but
as you know you can now buy insurance
online all those geico ads and
you know show you that you don't need
the sales guy coming in the door
anymore um home improvement contractors
come to your house and
talk with you funerals are still
sort of sold this way actually some some
funeral director still
but by and large it's vanished it
doesn't really exist it has no need to
exist today
direct selling and we don't need it
anymore there was
time when communications were primitive
people lived in isolated areas they were
home
a salesman could show up and and provide
a service and a product
it doesn't exist so that's the first one
it is disguised
as a business when it is not a business
and the second one
is that it actually provides an income
opportunity
so you've got a a disguised business
claiming to offer a broad-based business
opportunity
in fact this advertises the greatest
income opportunity in the world
and that millions of people are making
good money
at it and this is i say this is
a big lie because a big lie by
definition is a lie so audacious
and and that the average person could
not believe
someone would have the impudence the
arrogance the audacity
to say it unless it were true
and so to to take a model that we just
described
uh that actually has no external market
in which everybody's losing
90 some percent everything yeah yeah uh
that claims that you could in the 21st
century sell commodity goods from your
home and make
a lot of money these are absurdities
that are perpetrated as reality and
they are said so aggressively with such
authority with the government at
right over their shoulder saying it's
all true it's legitimate it's real
and they have celebrities endorsing this
you know and they have sports stars and
so on to where
the mind as in all big lies
can be overwhelmed and you can create a
mass
delusion that defies
logic where people can say even when
they
lose and this is the second
level of deception and i think anybody
that explores we we're talking about it
sort of we said the first step
kind of the first step is is breaking
free of the idea that it's a business
that it's direct selling business
that it moves products and so on that
it's based on
but after you that's that's sort of the
lie that's the delusion
that all of us are left with culturally
imposed
it's being challenged today for sure
but it has decades it has been imposed
decades into the
public mind right but what happens when
you get in
so you sign up your cousin your friend
somebody
invites you to it you get into the
meeting
you hear all this you sign up
within a month or two months you realize
first nobody's retailing these products
and actually you can't
you see that plainly you don't have to
be a sales
you know business person to to realize
this
nobody needs these things or that
they're high priced and
besides they're in stores and and
besides
they're telling me on the one hand sell
it and then on the other hand they're
saying recruit
but if i recruit my next door neighbor
he becomes my competitor
so it doesn't make sense so you conclude
oh i'll get it
it's not about selling it's not really
direct it's recruiting that's where the
business is
so now you're in there you realize that
much
and then of course you're having to buy
you discover you have to meet a quota
every month
for you to stay qualified so that after
i recruit you and two others
and you recruit for others i reap the
rewards but for me to reap those rewards
i have to maintain my own quota
so i'm gonna sell it so you're just
storing it right in your garage you
become the cut that's where you become
the customer you're saying
i'm the customer so you know uh all of
them will
tell you straight up 100 a month
vitamins what's wrong with that
buy that i mean it's good for you
well you don't know if it is but you
they say and then
it keeps you qualified and now you can
start getting in on the rewards
so now you're paying you're losing
you've realized it's not selling
and now you're losing so it's not income
why don't you quit
right why don't why wouldn't i quit and
rush out and tell my friends
whatever you do don't get into this
thing
it's i mean it's not what it appears
it's the opposite of what it appears
why don't they i'll tell you why i'll
tell you why because
this is something that i've had such a
gripe with and it makes me so
angry because i see it all the time all
of these things
have this brainwashing
i would say that occurs within the
scheme
and it's a big part of it i used to
think it was incidental but i think it's
a core component of what makes these
things successful
is they tell you that you're quitting
because you are somehow
less than or your failure and if only
you had kept on
you could have manifested this this is
the whole positivity
movement that is completely
taken over all of these things and i
like i said i see it in sort of a
parallel scam it's it's not as mature of
an industry as
multi-level marketing or is organized
but it's very similar where they tell
these people
oh yeah well these are for this these
results that we promised you at the
beginning these are for people who work
hard
and maybe i mean if you followed the
plan the plan works
maybe you're at fault maybe you're the
problem
and there's this incredible amount of
shame that goes on
with these uh with with i know
multi-level marketing but all these
kinds of schemes
am i getting somewhere near the ballpark
of the problem
absolutely as you said uh selling uh
positive thinking as a an absolute
tool for achieving success that is
telling you well you can be anything you
want
the key to it is simply changing your
mindset
um that in itself is can be a business
to go out and teach and preach that
you know and there are a lot of people
doing that and telling you it's not
about your training
it's not about the number of people
there's competency or competition
or or the market or the state of the
economy
where you live not about any of that
none of that matters
it's only about you it's all up here you
can change it if you can imagine it you
can make it hap
okay that's a business in itself but in
multi-level marketing
and many people call that a scam by the
way but it's a kind of
delusional story it's hard to nail it
down
there's always somebody that would say
yeah that hap that's exactly the way it
happened for me
i went through the course it became
transformed and my life turned around
but in multi-level marketing it takes
that very powerful story
that you just described involving
shaming
anybody can do it if you can imagine it
you can make it happen
prosperity thinking and then
they matched it up with an absolute an
actual
proposition an actual business
so it's one thing to sell it as a
general idea
but they took it and said now there's
your belief
and here's the business but the business
is a calculated
it is impossible for more than a
one or two percent a year to be
profitable because they need a hundred
others for them to be profitable in
other words it's a money transfer not an
exchange of value
so if i introduced you into
a room with no doors and said just you
know you can get out
no you can't because you're locked in
okay that's a trap and that's what
they've done
they've taken a belief system and
and you think how devious this is and
how
harmful this is if i can convince you
that everything's possible
and if if you should fail it will only
be your fault
you're you're losing at the most the
greatest income opportunity in the world
yeah if i lost the greatest opportunity
in the world wow
and you blew it and you blew it right
and it was only your fault because you
believe
anybody couldn't do this and you
imagined your success and you had
envisioned it
well they succeeded in two things they
shamed you when you leave so you're not
going to blow the whistle
but notice that in that process you
never did get out your calculator
and go five times five times five
you stopped thinking you stopped
believing your own eyes
which were they said it was direct
selling when i walked in the door but i
saw within 10 minutes it really wasn't
and they said that everybody could make
money but you know actually i haven't
met anybody personally
that is making money we're all losing
but you actually suspend that judgment
those
judgment you suspend your own
observations
your own experience and you substitute
it
with their imposed words
their authority so they literally
take your power away from you they kind
of
enslave you is mlm
what you're describing is almost like
some uh
religious very religious aspects to
the sort of the scheme now would you
personally
call it because i know you talk about
this a little bit in your book occult
there's a cult-like thinking going on
yeah
um yeah well i i just as we dissected
the model
to determine is it a pyramid scheme
it's forgetting legalities for a minute
just you know we understand what a
pyramid scheme is
unsustainable robbing peter to paypal
money transfer
and you take multi-level marketing apart
and it matches up
precisely with the pyramid scheme now
let's
do the same with a cult what are the
elements of a cult
and and they have been identified i mean
there are people that
spend their lives studying cults and
there are the specific characteristics
of a cult and one of them is the utopian
vision
another is proprietary language that
takes you out of your
fact-based experiential language and
puts you into this proprietary language
using words like multi-level marketing
calling sales calling recruiters sales
people
calling a money transfer a bonus plan
and so on
so they use specialized language they
use a brainwashing technique of
persuasion
which we already identified here of
separating you from objective reality
if you can imagine it you can make it
real nothing is actually real unless you
say so
they separate you from your community
and so that if someone says you know i
really
think you have to take another look at
this i've investigated it
it looks like a scam are you actually
making money are you keeping a record of
how much you've spending
they tell you get away from that person
that's a negative thinker a toxic person
cut them off
got them what you said but that's that's
my wife telling me that
you know how much is your wife's worth
maybe maybe that's what's holding you
back
maybe that's what's holding you back and
then of course they separate you from
your own identity
because they get you to imagine your
dreams
they already know now that you've
confessed in a way
that you are a dissatisfied person
you're disappointed in your life you
thought you had greater potential
you have longings for things that you've
not achieved
they know that so they will tell you
you know the reason you haven't
experienced these these
uh longings you haven't fulfilled
yourself it's you
it's the way you've been thinking you
say well i was brought up yeah well you
need to
separate yourself from all that and and
learn from the masters how to think how
to be
and now we have things for you to read
and and study and watch
so then and you need to be at these
meetings so they also
dominate your time so they have
controlled your environment
separated you from your own identity
separated you from your community
giving you a proprietary language to
speak
and then also put you into this utopian
thinking
realm and there are others elements to
it
they mystify it in other words
multi-level marketing
it has the secret to success well i have
a job i'm a school teacher
you know that's for losers the come to
this meeting these people
understand success that's it
they mystify it so mystification
and then the separation of your from you
from your identity from your community
the imposition of a language
these are all the elements of
brainwashing of a cult
now the problem people have when you say
that is they say well it can't be a cult
a cult is a business that can't be a
business
i mean cults deal in the occult they
deal
in abstract in metaphysical terms but a
business is so mundane
i mean profit loss
costs income i mean it's
there's a ledger you know an accounting
it's the opposite of a cult it if
anything will
will douse you with reality it's a
business but multi-level marketing is
not a business
first of all the government allowed it
to deal in the occult
when it allowed it to perpetrate
the delusion of an endless chain that's
an
infinite has infinite
you will not see apple or google
speak about infinite there are always
limits
there are always limits of resources
markets have limits
multi-level marketing is the only
so-called industry allowed to do that
so they have already been allowed to
traffic
in the occult and which are metaphysical
mystical terms delusional unreal
also also i've got us i've got to say i
think it's important to
notice this this uh this believe it you
will do it
while i i i think in an extremely
limited scope
like everyone can understand you know
you've got to be confident and stuff
like that
but they push it far beyond that it's
very much wrapped up in napoleon hill
in this christian science you know you
you're only limited by your beliefs all
this kind of stuff
you really quickly are heading towards
religious
language religious territory aren't you
absolutely you're you're engaged you're
you and that's why
when you go to most companies they put a
lid on that they may engage
in a bit of it of trying to get you to
bolster your confidence
you know have have a vision set goals
for yourself
have a plan and and and take
responsibility for your own life and so
on
but but they will not push it throughout
your whole life they don't try to impose
it and make it a way of
life for you in multi-level marketing
not only do they
push it to the total there are no limits
they will start talking to you about
your marriage your family life
your child rearing your religious
practices
what you do with your time your what do
you watch on television
they will it becomes a way of life but
then most important and i think this is
where it really crosses this
line they then attach it to a specific
business proposition of the of the
multi-level marketing
business here's 500 you you pay
you do now now you're saying i can you
can do all these things i told you you
can do you can make success
but they just gave you a plan that it is
mathematically
physically impossible for any but just a
tiny percent
to succeed at so you absolutely is a
cult
absolutely it is engaged in brainwashing
and by the way
they've been doing this for over 40
years the first mlms
both all three amway
coscott holiday magic had very
sophisticated
uh re-education programs mind
training programs so it's always been
hooked up with that
it's a necessary component because as i
say if they didn't do that
and within a day or two most people
would
probably figure it out this is not
working
this is not what they said it was and
not only am i quitting i'm warning
others
so the the flim flam uh
or a scam has always two elements one is
to get your money
the second is to make sure you don't go
to the police
and so not only and multi-level
marketing which is done now on an
industrial scale
they already took care of the police
police are in their pocket
what they're worried about is public
awareness
and that's why i say i think as we said
there is a shift occurring
not because there's regulations no there
certainly is not yeah
but because public awareness is growing
people are breaking the silence
they're not afraid anymore and you look
on the internet now
and and this podcast you're doing right
here is evidence of it
these are we're having a discussion that
i swear i could not have had 10 years
ago
like it just wouldn't nobody would ask
these questions
it was just considered out of bounds you
could say
some mlms are pyramid schemes yes well
tell me which ones and how do i know the
difference right and nobody could do
that
but if you said all of them are
essentially the same
you were considered out of bounds you
could never call them a cult
you could say they were cult like maybe
some of them
but you couldn't really get bore into
that subject and say
this looks an awful lot like
brainwashing undue influence
overwhelming critical thinking abusing
people's minds really you couldn't
say such things and finally
and this is the frontier that i think
most people have not gotten to yet
is this is all made possible because
of of really corruption of government
and that's the topic where i think most
of us
are if not just
hopeless we're almost perplexed
too because it's incredibly complicated
of okay
the government's corrupt what does that
mean
who's corrupt there has to be people
this is you're sort of blaming a
systemic structure but that in of itself
isn't super productive how do you get to
meaningful reform how do you get to
meaningful change
as an individual who's sort of talking
about it
um do you have any answers to that
surely you've thought
quite a lot about that oh god yes um as
i said i i've been to washington
i've met with people at the ftc i've met
with a few members of congress
and you know recently one hedge fund
tried to bring down
one large company herbalife
and they expended quite a bit of money
trying to
find out who in the government they
believed the ftc
would be persuaded by the facts and so
they spent
50 million dollars gathering those facts
publicizing those facts didn't work
you're of course talking about bill
ackman's very public fight with
herbalife and yeah he had a hard lesson
in learning that facts don't necessarily
matter
when you're talking about an industry
that has essentially
cornered the market on their own
regulation
um it it feels like we're in a time
where the only meaningful change you can
get out of the government
even with a perfect exposure of a
business is an
individual mlm being labeled oh we found
out that that was a oh
silly us that was a pyramid scheme all
along you know how could we have let
that occur
we're shutting that down and there's no
looking at the entire you know sea
of other mlms there's no thought that
hey maybe
all of these business models are based
on the exact same business model back
from nutralight
which was already rolled against way
back in the day maybe this is just the
same thing over and over again
let's do something about that that's my
personal frustration with this
is the um sort of microscopic view
that's been taken
is we're just going to prosecute
individuals
right yes and that i i think i diverted
us a little bit you had brought up this
this idea of unicorn and and i used that
in the book because
what the ftc has done as the complaints
rose
and they couldn't get away with just
saying it's legitimate direct selling
it was just too much evidence piling up
so they created a theoretical model here
under the theory multi-level marketing
is workable legitimate business and and
so it has all the same elements you
identified
yet somehow the people in it
earn sustainable profit from retailing
yes and the company earns its revenue
not from the
distributor so-called but from an
external market that's buying those
products
why they're buying them nobody knows how
you could manage to retail the product
under these conditions they don't answer
that
but they say but if it did it would be
legitimate
because the law
isn't really hasn't spoken directly
about endless chains we don't have an
anti-endless chain federal law
so we'll set that aside and we'll just
say
if more of the money came from outside
the chain that inside the chain
and so on if people weren't being harmed
because they were actually able to sell
the product profitably
you know it would be legitimate and you
say
okay in theory in theory pigs could fly
you know and everyone but okay yes in
theory i won't ever die
if i just think positively in theory
okay but give me some evidence now
show me one just give me one example
one you know company
the paragon the one that's
representative of this model
they've never given one they've never
given one
they've never they've never tracked
retail sales you're saying
no they they deliberately do not go and
look
so they don't find one company and say
there it is
all the people in there retailing
they're not just having to buy the
product themselves
there's an external market out there
there's people making money every day
just selling the product from their
homes like like in days of
old and happy customers and happy sales
people
and you say well what about all that
other the bonus the recruiting
well yeah that's there but it isn't uh
it doesn't characterize the company
okay which one would that be show me one
because i can't see how you could offer
people unlimited
income by recruiting and they somehow
don't avail themselves of it instead
they go out and sell in effect apples on
the street to their neighbors and
friends and they actually are able to
keep doing that and the friends keep
buying
these apples from them rather than going
to a grocery store
show me one it kind of doesn't make
sense they never do
so the theory is just a ploy
it's a agency ploy to avoid the
terrible reality well i yeah and the
terrible reality can be
seen or it you you sort of sense the
scale of it
when you see reagan
clinton bush all involved
with multi-level marketing these are not
some low-level uh you know state
senator it's not a federal it's not a
you know
a house of representatives person it's
not even a lobbyist
these are presidents that are
representing
these private companies and essentially
almost lobbying on their behalf because
of course if
clinton thinks it's great if bush thinks
it's great well this is just a
bipartisan issue we all think it's great
that is to me what's the most uh
disillusioning about it were you
disillusioning yes that's it
because what you see is that
the politicians have used
um and and i've tried to write about
this again put in historical times
1970s is actually now
economists show us was the high point of
the middle class
has been going down down down down ever
since
from the 70s on small towns collapsed
the industrialization the factories
closed
the downsizing the outsourcing
the employment flatlined you know the
income
pay wage levels flatlined costs kept
going up
health care became unaffordable college
became unaffordable
homeownership became unaffordable for
large numbers of people
and literally age expectancy life
expectancy
has is flattened or is going down in the
u.s
so something terrible has sort of been
happening
in the u.s our government and i'm not
speaking about polit
politicians of one party or another but
this was a huge
trends occurring they didn't actually do
anything about any of this
they let payday loans come in and charge
a thousand percent interest
they let private schools come in and
charge you know
students coming out with a hundred
thousand two hundred thousand of debt
people die because they can't get health
care they didn't deal with those
multi-level marketing help them by
saying
the american dream isn't dead it's alive
and well
it's better than ever it's a new thing
it's called multi-level marketing and
it's all up to you
don't come and complain it's all about
it's a wonderful story
that serves as a wonderful cover for
negligent or corrupting
politicians and they allowed that it was
very convenient
on the other side the public were
victimized by this
had no voice they didn't come forward in
throngs they didn't
drive up there in their tractors they
didn't carry signs
they were silenced shamed into silence
they were seething some of them
committed suicide
i mean i can't tell you in my work how
many divorces
i i've seen occur from people in these
things
young people dropping out of college uh
families just
ripped to pieces on this their lives
have been really
torn up by this delusional story that
was perpetrated and spread
like a virus here but it served
politically it was very convenient
for both parties who were essentially
doing nothing
about those broad trends that i
described
that have driven down the quality of
life in america
and other countries too to such an
extent that in
some countries when mlm enters
the people are led to believe this is
the epitome of capitalism this is the
free market
this is what it looks like sure and
i mean how ridiculous is that that a
pyramid scheme comes in representing
um market economies and it's it's just
it's just such a travesty and i think we
will
ultimately look back on this as one of
the great
follies and tragedies of our time
i think i'll look back at it like a
ponzi scheme i mean how did anyone ever
push this or allow this to be pushed who
was falling for
why and i think you know these
i do think it will eventually become
illegal i think i think
you only get a bigger body count as you
go
there's no evidence so you can do the
smoke the fanfare
but eventually people are gonna get it
you do see the public
backlash growing you see google outright
banning advertising pyramid scheme they
they outright say it
you know uh where the main purpose is
recruiting i mean
so there is a backlash that's not even
in the government realm and
maybe that will eventually be enough to
put
pressure and also awareness about these
problems out there to where
even your layman kind of knows it's in
the zeitgeist as you said
yes it is in the zeitgeist but i don't i
didn't in the book i didn't know if you
got to the end there
but i didn't raise hope for
reform from the government because i
can't myself right now name
a single member of congress
speaking out about this i can't and
um so far we there's not been a single
book
published on this subject nor a one
not even one comprehensive documentary
produced on the subject so the truth is
still
muzzled quite a bit but
as you said the voices are growing
they're bolder
they're younger and they're using tools
like this podcasts video channels and so
on
that are very powerful and they don't
need a publisher you know
to tell them whether they can censor it
or not and they
so i i i it is spreading and when it
gets to some critical point some tipping
point
then you'll probably see some
politicians getting on board
that's no i think you're right i think
there will be a tipping point and let me
tell you
um i think you hit on a key point there
which is that a lot of these things are
muzzled when enough power gets together
mlms find a way to capture it right and
they find a way to make it just enough
inconvenient enough and this happens
with all sorts of schemes i mean
let me tell you i had a i won't say who
but i had
a pretty large production company come
to me wanting to document what i talk
about as this big
kind of new scam especially during kova
there's this rise of scams going on
and we were two days before shooting and
they sent me a message saying hey
we love what you do we think it's
important but
it's too much of a legal liability we're
scared we don't want to put it out there
and i think that's been a lot of the
cause for silence for so long
is that the only methods of
communication were these big
companies and a big company doesn't want
to tango with another big company
in a drawn out lawsuit i guess
what makes me optimistic is increasingly
there's media channels that are not
constrained
by standard protocol it's harder and
harder
i know this i know this kid i was just
talking to him he did an investigation
he went into world financial global
and he brought in a pin camera right and
he made this big like
video about it and when he put it out
immediately he got a
he got a cease and desist letter from
world financial global
and his response was okay sue me
and it's just like you could never have
imagined that happening
with nbc putting out something like that
they never would
they never would do something like that
it's too risky it's too much of a
liability
and so that brings hope to me and i
think you have to give people hope i
think it's a curse of the human psyche
we have to have some level of hope
um otherwise it becomes too convenient
to
just not pay attention i think if you
don't have hope then it's well why am i
even
bothering you know yeah well i
i have uh in my own work and i said this
in the book
i because remember you said you asked me
the first question you asked how long
have you been doing this
can you can you endure 22 years without
hope i've been sued i was
involved in a large lawsuit one of these
harassing lawsuits went on for five
years
wow and um and i've watched website
after website go down
under these threats in the past i've
seen so many people just
back out of speaking whistleblowing
under the pressure and
and yet what i have observed uh tracing
this
over time and being a part of it it it
never stopped
people kept pushing forward they kept
they you know they kept going on
and i think the the the truth of
multi-level marketing the the real truth
is so compelling and the the the the
trend here the
phenomenon is so large so important
it will not endure it can't hold
you know it can't hold everybody down it
can't keep these voices down
so people are speaking people will keep
speaking
i've kept speaking but not because i
could see some end point
because after 22 years you stopped
looking for an end point
you you just you just mark it you just
mark your
your days and your months as they go
along right as long as you know
you're grounded there are people getting
it
there are people growing that there you
see some change occurring which i have
certainly
observed and and that's where you you
gain your
your strength but you don't
get it really i don't think people that
have been in it for a long time
have helped have held on to a hope it's
just they couldn't see anything
you know you you just couldn't see
anything and
uh sometimes you know we look right now
you mentioned bush
uh i mentioned reagan and so on it went
on
but we now the current president of the
united states
was the chief most famous endorser
and promoter of multi-level marketing
for 10 years
the great for 10 years for 10 years so
you know it's it's not that they
influence the white house
they're in the white house they're the
king of the white house i know
i know uh
yeah it's there i mean and uh and and it
is not
partisan anymore it is a bipartisan
thing
the the maybe trump was the biggest
domestic endorser but who was the
greatest
international endorser madeleine
albright
madeleine albright she was bill clinton
secretary of state
she's a revered figure in the democratic
party it's not partisan
it's not partisan because neither party
has been addressing the fundamental
issues that multi-level marketing
exploits and multi-level marketing not
only exploits that
but gives cover to the political
uh operatives who are really negligent
ignoring people's lives and instead
they've offered them this
concoction of here drink this
you know kool-aid you drink this
kool-aid you'll feel better
and people do feel better for just a
little while
i i think it's important to just recap
here
um ml limbs
again this has to be my i've gotten
through probably two-thirds of the book
to answer your earlier point but um
my favorite realization though was
this thing was built on essentially a
con man
who was looking to make a fortune he was
already lying about his
vitamins all this kind of stuff he had
watched as these other con men were kind
of making their fortunes and stuff
and that is sort of the the the dirt in
which
mlm sprouted or pyramid selling if we
could refer to it as
as its first name that tells you most of
what you need to know
nothing's really substantially changed
the only thing that's changed is the
political
kind of power these people are wielding
and when you understand that you can see
it
sort of for what it is which is a
long deception that's mostly happening
in our government
because nothing's really changed with
the mlm formula
it's as it always was and so
that's that's that's ultimately what i'd
like to see even just
even maybe if you are uh politically
sort of nihilistic about about the
outcome
i think we can return to that public
place and so i want to thank you for
making a huge contribution to this
to this effort because i'm sure you hear
it all the time but i think you've done
an incredible service to so many people
who are trapped in this this loop so
thank you for that
well thank you for the acknowledgement
um
uh it is it is uh i'm very happy that
you've taken an interest in it too
and made it part of your work and others
have as well
so yeah i think i think there are many
positive things to
see that are occurring here and
hopefully
my book the the concept of ponzinomics
you know
ponzinomics is stated at the very
beginning as a
as a dif in the context of a definition
and the last part of the definition says
that a delusion like this
can never endure without state or
government
collusion yeah it has to be there
otherwise the
sheer experience of it and the awareness
of the public would cause it to collapse
but if if it has enough authority behind
it
to to back it up and hold it up
it can endure for a very long time as as
we have seen
but when enough public of the public
really
pierces it demystifies it
recognize it as cultic and understands
the elements of it that it's not a
business
you know it's pulling the curtains back
and you see the little guy with the
smoke machine and the levers and making
the sounds and that's it
and then it's over yeah
well guys um please go get yourself a
copy because i can't recommend this book
enough
not for nothing else the amount of
historical
digging and collecting you've done here
i think you deserve
you know a round of applause because
i've never seen i don't think anything
like this exists
as you point out i mean no it doesn't um
so
if you're if you have any interest in
multi-level marketing i know we have the
business of the 21st century robert
kiyosaki this should be the companion
piece to that
ponzinomics by robert fitzpatrick um
when is it coming out well by the end of
the year
and uh that's another part of the story
is uh
you know publishers are frightened of
this thing but fortunately we do have
yeah they really are just like your
experience with that
unnamed fair enough fair enough that's a
great
wishes are just like that for the same
reasons yeah
but you know we don't need them so
the the book will be out uh and in both
hardback and ebook
by the end of the year okay and uh yeah
so
when you publish it i will include a
link in the description just send me an
email
let me know it's out so if you're
watching this in the future
because i know that's uh you know that's
the magic of youtube if you're watching
this in the future and you can look
below the fold
in the description uh there will be a
link
very soon so thank you robert for coming
on the show
sharing your 22 years of wisdom about
multi-level marketing
and exploring the depths because i
wanted to get beyond the normal
the normal pale of what is multi-level
marketing is it a is it a pyramids game
so i think you really got to do that
today and i appreciate you coming on the
show
thanks great bye-bye now what do you get
[Music]
never should have trusted
[Music]
comes along